[Music]
hey you guys time once again for another
book review of the latest horror book
that i've read so this novel right here
it's actually the debut novel of an
irish writer named am shine i believe
he'd written some short stories prior to
this but this is his first full-length
one and it's fairly recent it came out
in october 2021
and it's called
the watchers this was another one that
came up in my kindle unlimited
recommendations because you know if you
read enough of the stuff like check out
enough of the books then they'll give
you recommendations that are kind of
similar and this is one that came up in
the uh you know synopsis actually
sounded really interesting so i ended up
reading it now i will say that
this is more
this is definitely a horror novel it's a
little bit
it's kind of based in irish folklore a
little bit um and it's kind of like a
monster type monster in the woods type
of story and it's really detailed really
descriptive very atmospheric
uh it's more creepy than scary but i did
really like
a lot of the folklore behind it like the
introduction of
monster which is kind of based on
a real well not a real monster obviously
but like a real monster from folklore
but has kind of its own thing going on
as far as i could determine um but yeah
i overall i really really enjoyed this i
think it would probably oh there's a
couple's like minor criticism that i
give it but i'll get into that a little
bit later
so the synopsis of this book is that
there's kind of a prologue at the
beginning
where there's a married couple whose
names are john and ciara
and it's kind of like their sunday and
they decide just for shits and giggles
they're gonna go out on kind of like an
adventure like they're just gonna go on
a drive they're not going anywhere
particularly and so they decide to set
out and do that now this is in galway in
ireland where the author is also from
so they kind of end up going this
circuitous route uh they don't really i
guess like the cell phone service craps
out they don't really end up knowing
where they're going and they're just
kind of making jokes about oh maybe
we're lost and stuff like that and
they're like oh [ __ ] we are actually
lost and they don't actually uh know
where they are and then once they get to
a certain point
uh the car dies all the cell phones die
like pretty much all the electronics die
it's like a dead zone type of uh
situation
and uh they end up having to go into the
woods
and
bad [ __ ] ensues so after this kind of
opening then we go to
i don't she's like the main protagonist
her name is mina and she's um you know
the the story goes back and forth
between her and like three other
characters
but she's sort of like the main
protagonist like she's the person that
we're most often seeing things like
through her perspective
so mina is uh an artist and she's like
single and seems happy to be so a little
bit of a drunk she kind of smokes but
she seems again like pretty happy with
she's not like bummed out or anything
like that
and she likes to hang out in the pub and
whatnot
uh but because she's an artist and money
is kind of she gets some but it's like
few and far between so she's always kind
of looking for like gigs you know what i
mean
so she knows this older guy who she's
friends with at the pub
and this older guy is always kind of
like has all these little money-making
schemes like you know 200 pounds here
300 pounds there whatever
so he says to her oh um i have this
friend who's like a bird collector like
an exotic bird collector up in connemara
which i think is how you pronounce it
and uh i have this really rare like
beautiful golden yellow parrot
and i need you to drive up there and
deliver it for me and he's gonna pay i
can't remember how much it was but he's
gonna pay some amount for it um and you
can keep most of the money just bring me
some of the money back and you know
it'll be good for both of us so it's
very random so she's going up to this
place she's never been to before to
essentially like deliver a parrot the
parrot never gets a name she basically
just calls him the yellow one you know
he he almost comes becomes like a little
bit of a character in himself in himself
like you know what i mean
so she sets out uh with she has a gps
and the guy you know the the drunk guy
hit the pub he's like perpetually drunk
old dude and uh he gives her directions
but they're not all that great
uh so it will surprise no one to know
that she basically ends up somewhere
around the same area where the original
couple ended up and the same thing
happens like her car breaks down her
cell phone won't work any like her cell
phone's dead and she's like well [ __ ] me
and she's kind of and the fact that
she's kind of like a loner
and she's kind of like happy to not
really have she has a sister but
the sister seems like kind of an [ __ ]
and is always like calling her to
you know [ __ ] on her life choices and
stuff so she doesn't really talk to her
all that much so she doesn't really have
that many connections so it's not like
anybody's going to miss her or come
looking for or anything like that
so
her car breaks down like right at the
edge of this big creepy forest
and
she looks all around there's still kind
of a road but there's nobody else around
like nothing else around
so she's like well uh obviously there's
nothing back the way i came so i'm gonna
like try going through this forest maybe
there's a house or maybe there's another
road or something like that so she picks
up the parrot
and uh you know a little bit of bottle
of water that she has and trudges off
into the forest
she's not in there too long before she
starts hearing
really horrible like inhuman
screaming which of course alarms her
quite a bit so she just starts to run as
you would
and then suddenly she sees like this
kind of weird looking like older woman
and she kind of pops out uh of nowhere
and she's just sort of like hey you need
to come in here like right now like
immediately
and then she notices that there's like
this weird not necessarily like a house
but it's almost like a bunker like this
concrete bunker type uh construction
in the middle of the woods and has kind
of like a light and a door and all that
kind of stuff so
you know mina's just kind of like uh
okay i don't really see any other
options at this point she's like you
know come on you're gonna get [ __ ]
killed
so she ends up going into this bunker
with this older older woman who turns
out to be named madeleine
so when she gets inside this bunker she
discovers that there are also two other
people in there there's like a 19 year
old guy
named daniel
and then there's also ciara who was the
wife of the guy john that we saw in the
beginning
now as it goes on it turns out that john
actually made it to the bunker also like
both of them did but then he decided he
you know a while back he was like i
think it was three or four days ago he
was gonna go try and get help or
something like that and he has not
returned yet so they're actually not
sure if he's still alive but they're
presuming that he's probably not
so mina gets there and it's this really
really weird situation like i said it's
kind of like a concrete bunker and then
there's like another door and then it
goes into this other room
and this other room has this whole
entire wall that's made of glass
and it's just like this bright light
like all the time
and she goes in there and it's like
there's all these locks and [ __ ] like
that and madeline was like you know when
the light is on we have to be in this
room otherwise the watchers will get us
now you never find out entirely and i
think this is this is really the only
criticism i had with the book is that
you never find out exactly i'm not
saying you have to find out exactly
because i know i always say like if you
over explain your monster then it's not
scary anymore but i think i would have
liked a little bit more about the lore
like i said it could be that they're
based on something that's really in
irish folklore and i'm just not as
familiar with it so it could be because
he does kind of make um a thing to them
maybe being like fairies not like you
know tinkerbell type fairies but like
actual fairies which are like scary and
mean
so it's kind of like that but the way
they're described like you don't really
get to see one until the end you mostly
just hear them and they have like these
horrible shrieking
sounds and then you find out later that
they can also kind of like mimic people
like they can sort of like not exactly
because they're still kind of [ __ ] up
looking but they can kind of like put on
people's faces and stuff like this
they're supernatural creatures
essentially and they've apparently been
in this
wood in galway for since whenever since
like before humans have even been around
and
you know not really many people know
about it so there's kind of like these
forests and it's like if you get too
close to it like all electronics like
[ __ ] die
and
then you're just gonna get like [ __ ]
eaten by them essentially
so this bunker
and i like i said i won't spoil like
anything more about it too much but this
bunker
however it got there uh madeleine the
older woman who saved mina from being
eaten by the watchers by dragging her
into the bunker
she says that she's been in this bunker
more than two years
now you can actually go out into the
woods in the daytime like you can go
around and forage and stuff and they
have been because like i said they've
been there a long time daniel and ciara
mata there's kind of like a weird
dynamic between the three of them like
when mina arrives madeleine is very much
like the boss you know what i mean she's
i want to say she's like a motherly
figure but she's a very very stern
disciplinarian she's basically like look
i'm trying to keep you dumbasses alive
um there are rules you have to abide by
them or you're going to get killed and
it's like and i'm you know i'm gonna try
and keep you alive but if you do
something dumb then i'm not gonna be too
sad if you get your stupid ass killed
again and she's kind of always telling
mina like these two are useless it's
like they're so
dumb and it's like they wouldn't do
anything like if i didn't tell them and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
now uh you kind of find out more a
little bit now ciara the the wife of
john she's still she seems like a lovely
like really really nice sweet person uh
she's still holding out hope that her
husband john is still alive out in the
woods somewhere but everybody else is
pretty sure that the watchers got him or
he would have been back by now but she
also seems like a little bit i don't say
she seems like a little bit of an idiot
but she seems like kind of she's very
like naive or like childlike
and daniel is you know kind of young and
he's a little bit
i don't know he seems like a little bit
cowardly and he doesn't he's kind of
like upset with the whole dynamic with
madeleine because he he ran away from
a a really strict father who was always
like berating him and saying he was
never good enough and he was never going
to amount to anything so it almost seems
like now he's trapped in this bunker
with a woman who's essentially doing the
same thing so he's kind of like beaten
down but when mina arrives with the bird
the parrot you know it kind of changes
up the dynamic a little bit because mina
you know a kind of immediate she's an
artist and she's pretty perceptive and
so she kind of immediately sees what the
situation is and she doesn't she doesn't
like take over from madeleine but she's
kind of like studying her like trying to
figure out
what it is that
that kind of made her the boss and
trying to figure out what her deal is
because she's kind of like watching her
being like i know she's not being
entirely truthful like she suspects that
madeline knows more about the watchers
than she's letting on
but she it takes her a while to like
figure out what it is
so most of the first i kind of like it
feel like the first two thirds of the
book is very claustrophobic because it's
set pretty much inside this bunker
because like i said
once night falls and there's like a
light that comes on like automatically
like in the bunker
um and madeline doesn't really tell them
why that is she just says the light
comes on as soon as it you know gets
dark outside and the watchers start
prowling around and when that light is
on we have to be like in the lower part
of the bunker like with the glass walls
the glass wall is there because they're
called watchers and they want to watch
them so it's almost kind of like he
paints it as though the creatures
like enjoy watching them like they're
their pets like in a fish tank or
something like that but if they get out
then they will absolutely eat them so
there's good that going on too
so uh so yeah so it's really like
claustrophobic with just these four
people and then so it's night time they
have this [ __ ] bright light on all
the time so obviously they're not
sleeping very well and they don't really
have a lot of food they have to go and
forage they've set some traps but at one
point like the watchers like [ __ ] them
all up but they have to keep putting
them like higher and higher up in the
trees and basically all they can trap
and eat are birds because
no animals will hang out in this forest
understandably so uh so daniel has had
to go out and keep climbing higher and
higher like to set the trap so the
watchers can't find them and they also
just eat like nuts and berries and stuff
like that so they're all kind of like
you know
slowly sort of like starving to death
none of them look all that good like i
said they're not
getting all that much sleep and there's
that kind of [ __ ] too
so
that's pretty much a as much of the
thing that i want to spoil because
at some point like i said at two-thirds
of it they're in the bunker and then
they
discover something else that makes them
think that maybe they can escape because
they've pretty much got to the point i
mean madeleine has been there the
longest
but they've pretty much got to the point
well we're never gonna get out of here
because you can't because the woodland
is so big that
by the time like even if you started
like super early in the morning you
wouldn't be able to get out of the woods
by the time night fell and then the
watchers would find you and get you so
they're pretty screwed but about
two-thirds in they do find something
that like changes their situation
somewhat and maybe gives them hope that
they can get out
so there is that too and then the end of
it has kind of a twist now some of the
people well it is a twist it's not kind
of a twist it's an actual twist now some
people like the reviews i read of this
like said they saw it coming i
absolutely did not but in hindsight like
once the twist happened i was like oh
duh like i should have seen it coming
but i did it i guess maybe maybe i
wasn't paying as close of attention as i
thought i was but yeah it did actually
surprise me i was like that way and then
i was like oh yeah i probably should
have figured that out and
maybe i'm not all that smart but yeah uh
so there is like a twist ending but like
i said i don't want to spoil any more
than that
so
this book is actually if you like irish
folklore you know like a yeah i don't
know like maybe a movie like the hallow
or something like that that's kind of
like the vibe that this gave me um
because that was kind of also about like
the woods and there was these creatures
in there that were kind of like
changeling type situation um so if you
like that movie too you would probably
also really like this book as i said
it's very very atmospheric it's very
descriptive some reviewers called it
like purple prose or it was very like
verbose or it went too much into
description
it does shade in that direction but he
does have like a really uh i really like
his writing style
but there were long passages where stuff
were just like described and while it
was beautiful
um sometimes it did go on a little bit
too long although it does like really
paint a picture in your head you you
will get a very clear picture of what
this woodland looks like what the
bunkers look like
all that other kind of stuff so i will
give it that it could have been maybe
slightly shorter but i'm it's really not
that big of a deal um i did see that
some uh some readers
really thought it was too much and like
couldn't get with it but
i didn't really find that um like i said
it is very descriptive and you could
call it verbose but it didn't really
bother me all that much um the only
other minor criticism i would have liked
to know more
about
the background of the watchers like they
there's some
i mean i guess it's understandable
that you know we're seeing things from
mostly mina's point of view who just
came in here like and she's like what
the [ __ ] is going on i was just taking a
bird someplace and all of a sudden and
then the other three like obviously
madeline's been there the longest so she
probably knows more [ __ ] but
like i said i guess it's understandable
if you're just like a person and these
are like these ancient beings that have
lived in these woods forever and like
nobody knew about them so nobody really
knows all that much about them and in
some ways that does make it scarier you
do kind of get there is a point like
toward the two-thirds mark where
where the monster like one of the
monsters is like described in fair
enough detail
but as i said it's not the folklore
behind them is not real
uh is kind of not really really gone
into all that much and i can't decide
i don't know like the more i think about
it the more maybe that's not a criticism
because maybe if it was over explained
like if they had some
like i don't know if they found some
book somewhere that said oh here we are
this is exactly what they are blah blah
maybe that would have like demystified
it a little bit because the monsters
actually are really scary and like
actually really
threatening because like and they can
the thing about the bunker is that it's
kind of like the way i pictured it it
was like two rooms there's like one room
that's you know sort of like the front
room that they call the living room and
it has like a fireplace in it but that
one has windows but they don't have any
screen or glass or anything like that so
if you don't get into like the the
reinforced bunker part like with the all
the locks on the door and like the other
room
and the glass wall uh then you're [ __ ]
because if you're just stuck in the
living room then the watchers can just
climb in the window and just eat you you
know at one point when they do get in
and they're trying to get like into the
thing and it's like really scary and you
can kind of see them like in shadow like
through the glass and [ __ ] like that but
you don't really get a good look at one
of them until
towards like the two-thirds like you
know right where there was kind of like
a change where they're trying to get
away
so yeah so overall i actually really
enjoyed this book quite a bit um as i
said it's very atmospheric it's very
creepy and i really like the irish
folklore aspect of it because it's a
monster that you don't
the way that the monster is it's kind of
like one that you don't see very much
like i said that has like a changeling
aspect to it but it's also just kind of
like a straight up
straight up monster in a lot of ways so
i thought that was really cool like a
really original take and honestly it
sucks you right in with you know you
getting lost in the woodland and all of
a sudden like some old lady is like hey
come in this bunker you know what i mean
it's like so it really like gets you
into the story right away uh but yeah
it's probably more like i said more
creepy than scary and it did kind of
remind me a little bit of that movie the
hallow
uh which i think is on netflix or
something like that i saw it like a
while back but uh if you liked that
movie you'd probably like this as well
because it's the same kind of vibe to it
but uh yeah overall very very good book
if you have kindle unlimited you can
read it for free on there so if any of
you have read it or want to read it
let me know your thoughts about it in
the comments and that will do it for
this tomes of terror and i will see you
guys on the next one bye